hallo mein name ist nun komm wir spielen
heute immer wieder neue late allerdings
diesmal nicht auf dem handy sondern auf
dem computer gehen erstmal ganz in die
welt gott will rain wähle einen tatort
hallo andere ziele als andere ziege ich
hoffe dass gegen die klamme der grafik
weil irgendwie ist die hier gerade nicht
so toll das ist genau die gleiche map
die wir auch auf menschen hatten ich
weiß nicht auf dieser sprungturm hier
auch vorher schon behalten wir das auf
dem handy gespielt haben aber das
klettern wir jetzt einfach mal hoch und
schauen ob wir von da oben ob er von
dauer
das sollte eine eigene disziplin war in
diesem scheiss turmhof bekommen das ist
ja unmöglich orden einfach nicht runter
am ziel gewesen fast ganz oben unter der
decke und wir können
was ist denn das kann ich dir nicht sehr
gut und ab hier aus trampolin dann hier
drauf sorgen dann würde nämlich ganz
schnell hier kam auf dem dach von dem
gebäude
nein ich sehe gerade da drin ist noch so
ein 3 von 30 mein gott das ist sehr
verstörend fliegen kannst du nicht
einfach um
das sieht nicht so gesund aus ich komme
hier gerade echt nicht aus ich bin hier
drin
ich hüpfe ich hüpfte wie ein spaß und
ich aber wir sind zumindest draußen
ich frage lieber nicht nach was das
jetzt war kann ich das mit wert habe
das war wieder sehr starke niveau doch
gesagt man kann jetzt hier wände
hochlaufen das heißt es stark siege
hatten wir die ziege nicht auf
irgendeinen namen gegeben
kevin genau das ist kevin die hat mich
gerade blöd angeguckt deswegen halte das
ist nicht wahr ich kann ich habe mir
dafür bekommst du deine ecke lernen doch
mal meine neue freundin hier kennen die
hat hier ist ein bisschen schüchtern
aber wirklich ganz gern kennenlernen hey
alles klar der ist ein bisschen
abgehoben gerade also wenn sie sich
nicht weiter stört dann habe ich jetzt
mit meiner freundin abnahm
obwohl eigentlich kann ja auch noch
mitkommen hier wenn ihr euch fragt wie
es aussieht wenn du keine tankstelle
geht so das liegt einzig nahezu immer so
aus wenn ihr euch fragt wie es aussieht
wenn lukas schläft so so sieht es
eigentlich immer aus kombi wir entdecken
jetzt ein abenteuer
genau wir entdecken ein abenteuer ich
glaube so dahin
man kriegt für jeden scheiß irgendwie
schief - ich glaube sogar wir hinten
waren wir noch nie also wir sind noch
nie hier hinlegen wie rumgelaufen
bestimmt ist jedoch wieder irgendwo
sondern zum teil was man finden kann
was passt denn hier ist vom
ausgeleuchteter weg die opfer sammeln
was passiert hier kann sein dass dieser
spiele tatsächlich in die story hat weil
sonst wäre ja nicht irgendwie sondern
opfer sammle altar ok und jetzt gerade
deswegen mein kompletter bildschirm
irgendwie kaputt gegangen dadurch dass
ich die macht viel mehr spaß
[Musik]
alles wird gut ich kann ganz einfach
wenn ihr euch fragt wie es aussieht wenn
ich auch mal griff hat ja und jetzt bin
ich wieder bei diesen blöden opfer
sammle leuten hinter ich will doch
einfach nur zurück zu meinem freund eine
gute schöne party mit euch feiern können
wir nicht einfach ganz in ruhe darüber
reden freunde großer peter kuster so
fällt dir einfach immerhin will doch
einfach nur eine brennende ziele auf dem
ich kann die alle anstecken ein wenig
über die verbrennt verbrennt von
bleibt mein gott wie meine augen
aussehen was ist eigentlich dahin das
habe ich mich nämlich in der letzten
folge in der vorletzten sich dann immer
die vorletzte folge da da könnt ihr euch
mal die vorletzte anschauen und auch die
letzte wenn ihr wollt halo effekt da
soll ich mich jetzt mal einen
mähdrescher das ist ja kein ding dann
gehe ich einfach mal ganz kurz hier
alles klar was gucken kann ich irgendwie
dieses ding reingeht teil steuern
ich nehme das mal als ein nein das macht
ihr hier vorne machte irgendwie so die
jubeln mir zu die ihr habt nicht
wirklich hab ich den gerade getötet muss
draußen runde zwei weg mit dir sage 3
ich habe ich oder die auf die heiligen
einander du auch raus aus dem treibhaus
super runde vier ich will doch auch kein
schwein haben soll und mit fünf ganz
klar und jetzt bin ich glaube ich bin
voll muskulös geworden aber ich würde
schon sagen freunde das war's jetzt mit
diesen teilen